I've only been eating meat for beef
fundamentally for almost five years now
I never imagined in my wildest dreams
number one that you could just live on
meat and number two that it would have
such a salutary effect so for me I lost
52 pounds in seven months I went from
212 pounds to 165 which is exactly what
I weighed when I was 23 and I've
maintained that weight since I could put
on muscle Mouse with no problem even
though I'm 62. I had a host of
inflammatory conditions some of which
were quite serious including peripheral
uveitis which sometimes blinds people in
my right eye and it disappeared
completely along with psoriasis and
gastric reflux disorder and
interestingly enough
gum disease which is technically
incurable which is linked to
cardiovascular degeneration and which
has gone away 100 percent in my case
according to multiple measures that my
dentists have taken and so when I've
talked to many people who've lost like a
hundred pounds in a year you know
because they come to my talks and who
are just beside themselves so to speak
as a consequence of experimenting with
this diet the food pyramid was actually
produced by not by scientists or by MDS
although there were some MDS
who were Consulting who were mostly
ignored but by the Department of
Agriculture
and it was a marketing scheme
essentially and that the consequence of
the marketing scheme was that people
were enticed and convinced to rely
primarily on carbohydrates for their
nutritional
necessities and perhaps carbohydrates at
far too excess at a level now
carbohydrates are transmuted into
glucose during metabolism and we eat way
more carbohydrates than we need to
produce the amount of glucose that we
need now people have been getting fatter
in a catastrophic way for about four or
five decades and that's really
in those small parts since the
introduction of the food pyramid now I
do understand that part of the reason
the Department of Agriculture did this
was because carbohydrates and this was
particularly true of corn syrup do
provide a very inexpensive source of
calories and if you're dirt poor and you
don't have enough to eat I mean just
getting enough calories period is of
vital importance not everybody can
afford steak for example or or or or
more expensive foods of that type but
virtually everyone pour an odd in the
West can afford basic carbohydrates
having said that I also have red and I
think it's valid that there was early
evidence that this heavy
carbohydrate-loaded diet that was being
prescribed was going to increase obesity
and diabetes which is done in at a level
that makes the pandemic epidemic look
like absolutely nothing and and this is
still being pushed forward by people who
are hypothetically on the nutritional
front as you may or may not know my
daughter was very ill with a plethora of
immunological problems including very
serious juvenile arthritis and that was
it just about killed her it did destroy
two of her joints and she had another 38
that were affected and so she was always
in a lot of pain and we I looked into
the role the diet bleed in arthritis
through the scientific literature for a
couple of years and found two things and
and they were somewhat contradictory and
one was that
there was no real evidence that any
specific elements of diet had been
linked to juvenile arthritis
specifically but
and this was a major but
if people who are arthritic fasted
completely then their arthritic symptoms
often disappeared
and so I thought that had something to
do with the consequences of fasting but
then my daughter started to play and my
wife as well very intensely with the
diet we went to a nutritionist who
recommended Elimination Diet at one
point because we did notice that she
would react to strawberries and oranges
we could that and within a day her
thumbs would swell her toes would swell
it so we knew there was some things she
was eating we had her tested for
immunological reaction to food but when
we tested her she showed a hyper
reaction to virtually everything they
tested her for and we concluded at that
point well there's no damn way she could
be reacting to everything she's eating
well she went on this Elimination Diet
and showed a bit of reduction in symptom
but the Elimination Diet made no sense
like there was no Rhyme or Reason to
what you could eat and what you couldn't
eat and so she started to experiment
with more restricted diets and
eventually settled on discovered that if
she only ate beef and it turns out for
her it has to be beef that isn't aged
then all of her immunological symptoms
disappeared and then my wife and I
started playing with that diet and so
I've only been eating meat for beef
fundamentally for almost five years now
and I eat a lot of meat and a lot of
high fat meat and so I'm never hungry
and I don't think that I'm calorie
restricted at all because you know I can
eat all a Tomahawk Steak sometimes in
one sitting which is about 35 ounces of
meat I never get hungry and I eat
high-fat carnivore snacks too the diet
has actually been rejuvenating for my
wife and I like its effect on muscle
tone has to be seen to be believed and
that's true even though both of us are
60. like my wife is in better shape from
a musculature perspective now at 63 than
she was when she was 40 and she was a
very physically fit person who was
exercising constantly and who was in
pretty damn good shape and to see that
reverse rather than just you know stop
deteriorating I don't really know what
to make of it the reason that beef works
and that other ruminant animals bison so
forth uh
um lamb goat is because
they process what they eat through so
many stomachs that by the time it is
actually turned into meat there's pretty
much nothing else there so it's
it's a very purified form of nutritional
uh uh very well a very purified form of
food now like I said that's anecdotal
and this is partly why I don't talk
about it but but I can tell you after
you've talked to a thousand people who
tell you the same anecdote you don't
have an anecdote anymore you have a
hypothesis and it's really quite
something seeing these people who show
me pictures of what they looked like a
year ago and you know they were carrying
around an extra person with them and
they're still Shell Shocked by the
transformation you know because it's
really something to lose say 150 pounds
in a year the advantage two of the diet
the carnivore diet particular is because
you can eat as much as you want it's
actually not a diet you know the problem
with diets is that they require
privation and they require almost
continual privation and then they also
tend to produce a yo-yo effect and
that's partly because if you get in a
fight with your hypothalamus which
drives hunger you're going to lose
because it's there to make damn sure you
don't starve and the probability that
you can override it for any length of
time
but it's very very low and that probably
varies from person to person for all
sorts of reasons but you don't want to
get into scrap with your lower level
motivational systems now you know if I
ever start to crave a banana split for
example I can just eat another five or
six ounces of steak and then I don't
care it's not like it wouldn't taste
good you know but it doesn't preoccupy
me the way it would if I was hungry I've
really noticed this when I go into
grocery stores because if I go into a
grocery store after having consumed
enough meat then the provision of this
infinite display of delicious foods
really doesn't affect me much but boy if
I ever go into a grocery store when I'm
hungry that's quite the pain in the neck
because everything's delightful and
tempting you know so the fact that you
can eat enough or even as much as you
want on a keto or carnivore diet does
seem to distinguish it in some ways from
the diets that depend more particularly
on mere calorie restriction I noticed it
as I got older my ability to concentrate
when I was reading was deteriorating so
when I was 25 30
when if I picked up a book and read it I
would
shut everything else out and I would
remember concentrate on focus on and
tend to what I was reading read every
word and understand it with no problem
but that started to deteriorate as I got
older and I noticed that it took an
increasing amount of effort to shut
everything off and that instead of
reading as deeply as I was I was sort of
glancing at the words
and when I started this carnivore diet
that reversed and I can now I think I
actually think this is true I think I
can read faster and more efficiently
than I could when I was in my 20s and I
was pretty good at it when I was in my
20s and so the other thing that I've
noticed too is that I don't have periods
of time this was quite a problem for me
and it might have had something to do
with my immunological problems is that I
would get
hypoglycemic and lose the ability to
concentrate and get what do they call it
hangry you know hungry and angry and
irritable and that would happen several
times a day probably because I was
working too much but in any case that is
gone completely
and I really don't miss it you know I
wake up in the morning with a stable
mood and my mood doesn't vary much
throughout the day I'm also much more
stress tolerant and able to re bounce
back from stressors faster and in terms
of
endurance
you know there were lots of times over
the last three years when I was walking
nine to 12 miles a day on a carnivore
diet now I wasn't running you know but
my experience is that I'm stronger and I
have more stamina than I did 10 years
ago
and that's quite something given that
I'm now 62.